i just feel like it's now time to have
another kid
ah yeah you heard that right khloe
kardashian just told
tristan thompson it's time to have
another kid
on thursday the trailer for the 20th and
final season of keeping up with the
kardashians dropped
and revealed a sneak peek at a private
convo between
coco and tristan i just feel like it's
now time
to have another kid yeah that's all they
gave us
but what a doozy wow isn't that crazy
of course the good american founder and
the nba player share a two-year-old
daughter
true i'm really just enjoying my life
and they rekindled their romance in
august
after more than a year apart at the time
a source told et the couple is back
together and things have been going
really well
i'm just super happy and content the
athlete was previously involved in
multiple cheating scandals including one
with kylie jenner's former bestie
jordan woods you know things happen and
of course i'm sorry
but they always made sure to maintain a
positive co-parenting relationship for
their little girl
it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
and naturally the road to reconciliation
was documented by
keeping up cameras he's still in love
with you
no and i i know that but i think i feel
a little more
pressured even my family is like so are
you guys sleeping together or not i'm
like no we're not
and then he's never said i need an
answer but i always feel like
he needs an answer so like what are we
doing back in december a source told et
that chloe and tristan are still working
on rebuilding their relationship and
trust
and they were planning to split their
time between la and boston
where tristan is playing for the celtics
i 100
have a block up but who wouldn't in the
season 19 finale chloe opened up about
breaking down the walls she's built
every relationship i go into they're
always
disappointing and dumb so i have every
reason
to be guarded i have every reason to
have these
bricks up in layers and if somebody
cares enough
they will take those bricks down brick
by brick we'll have to tune in to see it
all go down on the final season of
keeping up with the kardashians when it
premieres march 18th
on e
you